Hi welcome again to invade.com my name is Adam today.
We're going to look at something that I get asked
about all the time so I would that I lost
my cap there,
OK, so people students. Ask me all the time?
What's the difference between though,
although and even though and despite and in spite of
very simple.
It's not as complicated as everybody thinks first.
Let's start with these 3.
These 3, though, although and even though these are used
with adverb clauses.
Now just to refresh your memory?
What is a clause a clause is any group of
words that has a subject and a verb it must
have a subject and a verb.
And these 3 are used to show contrast.
So what does all this mean in general,
you're going to have a long sentence this sentence is
going to have 2 clauses.
One clause will have this adverb marker in it.
The other clause will be an independent clause means it's
a sentence that can stand by itself.
And this does is it shows a contrast or something
that's very different from one clause to the other clause
so within that one sentence.
You have contrasting ideas like positive and negative or you
think this is going to happen,
but it really that happens,
something very different from what you expect.
Despite and in spite of these are prepositions.
And they are used with a phrase now,
what is a phrase a phrase is also a group
of words.
But it doesn't need to have a subject in a
verb.
It can have a noun or it could have a
verb or it could have neither but usually it has
at least one or a gerund,
but we'll get to that,
but it also shows contrast.
OK, before I give you some example sentences to understand
all this,
let's look at each one separately,
though, and although what is the difference?
No difference, though, is this a little bit more informal
you can use either one at the beginning of a
sentence or middle of a sentence.
The biggest difference is that you can end a sentence
with,
though you can't really end a sentence with although and
again when you end a sentence with,
though. Formal sentence OK, so you have to keep that
in mind,
so informal. Now that doesn't mean that this is formal.
It just means that this is informal if that makes
any sense.
How 'bout even though even though also shows a contrast
but it's a much stronger contrast it adds emphasis?
But what is the emphasis on OK this is?
What is important? What is the emphasis placed on the
expectation?
So for example, the beginning of the sentence has one
idea so you think this must be the second part,
but no something very different is the second part and
this is a very strong emphasis on this expectation.
When I give you some example sentences,
you'll understand what I'm talking about.
Despite and in spite of these are exactly the same
except one word 3 words for this one right.
But they work. The exact same way you can interchange
them.
One mistake that many people do they say in despite
of or this?
Despite of something they mix them be very careful.
Despite your face. In spite of your face don't mix.
The 2 up. There 2 different things with the same
meaning OK.
This will be much clearer once I put up some
examples,
so let's do that.
OK let's start with although though,
and even though I have basically the same sentence for
different ways OK.
Although the exam was difficult.
I think I did well now here.
The contrast is between difficult and doing well right.
That's the contrast difficult means doing badly.
But here is an opposite OK very easy.
I started with although I'll give you the opposite because
you're a subject and here is your verb and then
here's your subjects and here's your verb again.
We want to talk about the extra clause at the
end there.
That's your main one now same sentence I can switch
it around.
I can say. I think I did well.
Although the exam was difficult beginning and doesn't matter.
The only difference would be the comma.
If you put this as the second clause.
No comma if you begin a sentence with the adverb
marker you have a comma.
I think I did well,
though the exam was difficult.
OK. So that's
My mistake there sorry about that here we have it
in the second part I could put although here,
I could put though here,
both would be OK doesn't change the meaning of the
sentence.
One is just informal one is just regular no problem.
Here, what I did is I wanted to show you
how to put it at the end,
so I split up the sentence into 2 the exam
was difficult.
Period sentence is finished. I think I did well,
though. Now here I put a comma when I put
bill with the end now again.
This is informal. This is people how people speak sometimes
you can have it in writing,
but not in formal writing,
but you see how I can put us at the
end.
I can't put although here that doesn't work.
You have to use it,
though at the end of the sentence in informal situations.
Now here I change the sentence a little bit even
though the exam was easy.
I failed now, what's the difference here?
The exam was difficult. I think I did well so
there is a contrast,
but it's not very strong contrast right.
Here the exam was easy so if I hear the
exam was easy.
I expect that you did,
very well right. That's the whole idea.
But I failed that's drastic drastic means it's completely different
result than what I expected.
That's why I'm using the even though even though it
was easy I failed.
This should not happen. After this right so the difference
is so strong from the expectation that you want to
use even though to emphasize.
Seems that difference OK, I hope everybody understands that more
or less.
Their exact same in most situations.
You can use any one of the 3 it won't
make that much of a difference.
This one has a certain feeling to it.
A strong difference. So when you're writing an essay for
example,
sometimes it will make a difference.
Even though or although but usually not.
Let's look at despite in spite of OK.
Now let's look at despite and in spite of so
first of all.
His best efforts, the man just couldn't succeed.
Sorry forgot to put a little period,
there at the end, OK now first?
What does it mean it means he tried his best?
He tried and tried and tried but always failed could
never succeed now?
What do you notice about this sentence here?
There is no verb right.
It's only a phrase. This is what we call a
phrase here,
you have your regular independent clause with your subject and
your verb no problem.
In spite of his best efforts,
the man just couldn't succeed exactly the same meaning OK
this one expression versus the other.
Again, I can change it around the man just couldn't
succeed.
Despite his best efforts, the man just couldn't succeed.
In spite of his best efforts,
same, meaning another way, we can use despite and in
spite of is with a gerund an ING verb.
This is called a gerund.
It's an ING verb, but we use it like a
noun so here the phrase is being on time.
To the lecture not so important,
so despite being on time means,
although he was on time see.
I can make some up.
It's exact same meaning we were not admitted we were
not allowed inside,
so keep in mind, despite and in spite of mean
the same as although but despite and in spite of
we use with the phrase.
Although we use with 'cause.
Otherwise, same, meaning if you're not sure and you still
have some questions,
please go to. Dot com there's a quiz there,
you can try all these things out and ask your
questions and I'll see you next time thanks.